hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today is Thursday we it is dev
streamed recap day and we have tons of
info on the new season 6 event called
Rite of Champions and it has we have all
the new details weapons effects loo new
game mode and more about this entire
event but two really quick things first
up is the weekly livestream that I like
to do every Saturday around 1 to 2 p.m.
est I do this about every week and I
chill with you guys and play some
subscriber games since you guys are the
best so come by chill out with everyone
at about every Saturday and as well I
did a collab with my boy Talon
who you probably have seen in my live
streams and comment sections a lot we
play lots of brawls and destroyed a
bunch of people it was a heavily edited
video and I had lots of fun doing it
here's a really quick clip of what to
expect from the video so like I said
check the description it will be the
first thing in the description for that
Talon is almost at five thousand subs so
it'd be absolutely amazing if you guys
could subscribe and watch his video so
we can hit that sub goal he does a lot
of shaman and Valkyrie gameplay and he's
really good so let's try to hit that
five thousand subs just for him but now
let's finally get into the news today so
first up the character swap glitch that
you may have seen on YouTube with the
executions and just the moose has - in
general has been patched and the
tournament rewards may possibly be
changed because of the community's voice
on the season 6 tournament rewards which
if you guys don't know these season 6
tournament rewards are supposed to be
one ornament for every single character
it's basically a copy-paste so they may
come up with something in the future
because the community voice their
opinion and we don't really like it but
to get on with the news that you
actually care about the new season 6
event is called bright of Champions and
it goes from May 17th to May 31st in the
event the atmosphere is going to be
changing meaning new menu music and vs.
music which is always nice a new face
off screen which shows the champions in
the background and new looking soldiers
as well which has always been changed
every single event every time they do
this last week we talked about before on
a road map and that had orders with
pictures of the three champions and now
we have more info on what those are but
those pictures the road map were
actually community events first is Belle
Valle the Medusa so from today March
17th until the 21st of may be the first
faction to play matches with night
heroes to win steel and crates
next week is musashi and it's the same
exact thing for May of 21st to May 27th
be the first faction with the
matches played as samurai heroes and
then the last week is he drew and that's
from May 27 to the 31st which is the end
of the event and it's to be the first
factor in employ the most matches with
Viking heroes
you'll beginning steel and crates as a
reward to definitely try to participate
that throughout the entire event on top
of that there's also going to be 18
special contract orders specific to
every character and for honor that
basically tells a facts story and we're
going to be getting some decent Lou and
all that stuff there wasn't really stuff
mentioned on what that specific loop is
but it's going to be character specific
and these contracts bond daily every
single day throughout the event so make
sure to log onto for honor every day and
do those specific hero ones so you can
get those rewards on top of that the
event also has limited time cosmetic
loop which comes in with a new ornament
a color swatch available for all heroes
any limited time effect called radiant
which is basically like a lens flare to
your emotes executions etc and it's
glued Abul throughout the entire event
by playing matches during the event I
will have a video in the coming days I
hunt to get the loot the fastest for
this event so don't worry if you're
stuck I got you guys covered on that
there also be legendary weapons for each
character that is going to be coming
with this event they strayed away from
the flashy go look to add a more
simplistic type of steel and gray style
which absolutely looks amazing these
weapons I'm going to be showing are only
during the event so do not get these
confused with the weapons I showed a
couple weeks ago those weapons bore for
the entire season these weapons I'm
about to show now are for the entire
event which is only from May 17th to May
31st
two very different things for the
weapons the first batch I grabbed from
the stream was warden sent peacekeeper
and conquers weapon next up is law
bringers gladiators Kenzie's and Nobu
she's the third batch is Orochi shougo
ki shinobi and ARA Musha the fourth is
Raider Berserker Valcke and Highlander
and then the last two are warlord and
shaman like I said these are only for
the event and it can be lootable
throughout the event and you can also
get them through scavenger crates and
loot after the matches next up is the
mask outfits and these are similar to
the champions shown in the trailer he
dragged a bail vault in Musashi I will
have the video on-screen playing in the
background and personally I have to say
the Knights have the best mask outfit
this event all these are really cool
looking but I personally to me the
Knights have the best one and if you
don't know these masks can be used
through the idol emote and execution as
well just like normal of course
so if these interests you you should
definitely go buy these in terms of the
price it will be fifteen thousand steel
during the week of May 17th to the 24th
so the first week and then we'll go back
up to 20,000 steel once the week is over
because next week the new content of the
week is going to be a sword in the stone
free room emote available for all heroes
and that is going to be from May 24th to
May 31st then it is disappearing so to
recap just in case you were confused
that the masks will never disappear and
you could buy them any time you want
even after the event is over but they
will be discounted for the first week
that they are out so it's probably
better to get them now instead of later
but the sword in the stone email will
disappear if not bought during the
second week
so by that while you can and the weapons
I showed earlier will only be available
for the event if you do not have them
after the event is over they will
disappear and then next up we have the
new game mode and this is going to be
called the carousel of death and if it
sounds similar to it a recent mode that
we've had you're exactly on point all
members of the opposing team must be
dead for the round to finish it is best
of three rounds so first team to two
rounds wins it is single pick heroes
meaning you cannot have two Raiders or
more or any like combination on the same
team and no feeds or gear stats so just
pure skill this is very similar to dance
of death except with four V fours
instead of two V twos and it's only on
the arena Maps which if you've played
the arena maps you do know that there
really isn't a lot of space for eight
people so this is absolute utter chaos I
will have gameplay of the new game mode
to see what you're expecting while I've
been explaining this and as you can tell
every time you die it adds a timer to
the respawn on the top right which of
course is just like dance of death
except this time if you die in carousel
of death
it adds five seconds to your respawn
time instead of one second like in the
original dance of death and it's also
the best of three rounds like I've
stated before so all you have to do is
win two rounds in a row and you win the
game and then lastly to end the video
today there's also a discount on all
heroes throughout the entire event and
that includes all the original cast and
dlc dlc characters are going to be
costing ten thousand steel instead of
fifteen thousand and if you have the
starter edition which is only on pc the
individual hero will cost five thousand
steel instead of eight k and if you buy
all the heroes together the bundle will
come out to 31,000 steel and as well
revamp champion status will also be
included which adds
40% more xp for you and 20% for your
teammates as well as more loot and
salvage and lastly the champion status
is also 30% off until the end of the
event so if you wanted to wrap up your
character really quick or get a new one
definitely go with that the reason they
had this discount is because of the
contract orders for every specific hero
they want everyone to have the
accessibility to get all the heroes so
that they could possibly all the
contractor Ward's completed so that is
why they decided to give us a discount
on all the heroes if you don't happen to
have any of those missing or anything
like that and that's gonna be the end of
the video today guys hopefully you guys
did enjoy as always the question of the
week is gonna be what is your favorite
thing about the new seasonal event Rite
of Champions is it the new mask outfit
the new game-mode anything like that I
would love to know in the comments below
what your thoughts are so we can get a
discussion talking with everybody else
just to reiterate previously I do have
that livestream on Saturday hopefully
you guys will join me on that and as
well click the top link in the
description to go to talons video let's
try to hit him past 5000 subs he's very
close liked the video if you did enjoy
it really does help me out subscriber
for new I covered the informational site
a foreigner that being the patch notes
new events balance changes leaks of
heroes anything like that future updates
all of that I like to cover on for honor
my two most recent videos are gonna be
on screen if you guys do want to check
those out and if you haven't seen them I
highly recommend you do and with that
guys hope every great yesterday and
peace out enjoy that new event